we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
about social democracy and technological
unemployment hey david my name is justin
I'm from Washington State and my
question is as a social democrat should
we be opposed to automation taken
service jobs away from working-class
people thank you okay so this this is a
really good question whether you're a
Social Democrat or not the the right
answer here is a simple one
historical efforts to oppose technology
on the basis that it would destroy jobs
have failed period we could probably
find some examples where there has been
a successful effort to suppress a
technology at least temporarily on the
basis that it would destroy jobs but
historically saying we need to suppress
this coming technology because people
will lose their jobs has not worked what
we need to take seriously is rethinking
the relationship of humans to work for
example technological automation if you
imagine a business with a hundred
employees technological automation could
make fifty of those employees
unnecessary and one way that the
business could respond would be to say
we're replacing 50 employees with
machines we're keeping 50 employees 50
people lose their jobs it doesn't have
to go that way the other way that it
could be done is the business says well
what we're going to do is keep all of
our hundred employees but they'll each
work only two and a half days a week or
four hours a day instead of eight or
whatever else now obviously the business
is not going to be willing to use the
entire gain from the technology and give
it all to the workers but maybe they say
we'll keep our hundred employees and
they can work six or five hours a day
instead of eight and we will sort of
split the gains from the technology now
obviously there needs to be some reason
that the business would choose to do
that and there are people including Bill
Gates who have started floating ideas
and and and sort of thinking about
different ways in which we might be able
to make that happen but no I think that
it's not only misguided I think most
importantly it's a futile effort to try
to oppose the technology on the basis
that jobs will be lost we need to
rethink how the gains from these
technologies should be
distributed and that's where 90% of the
issue is okay I will tell a bunch of
vacation stories on the bonus show today
including two dog poop stories I don't
know that we've ever really had dog poop
stories on the show and I regularly
visit Argentina so it makes it all the
more incredible that there haven't been
dog poop stories on the show anybody
who's walked around Ueno situs will
understand what I mean but I do have two
dog poop stories today and a whole bunch
of other stuff become a member or a
patron to get instant access to the
bonus show